so what do you make of the recent ufo
hearings
yeah so i i i watched them and um
i found them to be interesting
i don't have a lot to say about them in
the sense that you know
the specifics you know do i think that's
you know we've moved ahead with them um
with the topic of ufos and things like
that
um i would look at it in the sense that
uh
um
here give me some time because i have
thought about this but of course now
i've blanked out on it i can't remember
what i was gonna say
okay oh i'll give you something i'll
give you some time so do you want me to
just be silent while you think
yeah just give me some
silent time to like kind of um okay so
um
all right
okay okay this is it all right
me looking at this okay looking at these
hearings um and based on my experience
of the last
few years well more than a few years
maybe six or seven years where in i
identified what i'd call like a fight
club
of people who are involved in you know
the study of uaps and ufos um and what i
mean by fight club is i mean that peop
these people are
compartmentalized and they don't talk to
one another
um i can't see how a hearing a
congressional hearing is going to
pierce any of the information within
that fight club i think what's happening
is that there's a recognition that there
is this this group of people who do this
kind of study they probably you know
they're probably different factions in
fact there are different factions and
groups of them doing pretty high level
study of this stuff
but they're not talking to each other
okay
um they're not talking to each other
because that's how they've been trained
so so whereas you know we've already
talked you and i about academics and
this kind of academic ethos of sharing
our sources to
further and progress knowledge okay this
is this is actually a method and we
believe in it and we even believe that
this is right
okay well this is you know and for
better or worse it could be you know i
don't i now i was so surprised to hear
that
well i shouldn't have been surprised
the the fight club um and the
compartmentalization of these groups
is necessary for these groups to further
their knowledge okay
but it doesn't work in the same way that
we think democratic
progression of knowledge works does that
make sense
it works differently it works almost the
opposite so when i see the hearings i
hear that
it's a very it's i i think i posted
something on twitter where i said this
isn't the valet
level of talking about the topic right
it's not gonna get that way it won't get
that way
maybe ever okay we can't expect it to so
for what it was
um
it was it was okay you know for what it
was it was okay it was something that
recognizes at least and modifies the
stigma that's been attached to
ufos for the past 50 years okay and
that's a good thing that's good for me
because i wrote about it
and it's good for other academics who
want to go in and and study it it's good
for people who've seen ufos and have
felt like they couldn't tell anyone
about it so it's good in that way okay
um but is it you know frankly i think
that the fight club
of compartmentalized people who study
this is going to continue probably get
more funding even now because of this
but that's what i see
as the consequence of this i don't think
i have um
i don't see these two groups talking
yeah so it's not disclosure per se it's
more
the
creation of the environment that allows
disclosure slash research by removing
the stigma well research
remember research has already been
happening so um
i think it's removing the stigma